oh there's like the guilt of like
supporting the minorities
[Laughter]
[Music]
a hot dog vendor was stabbed in an
alleged turf war with another hot dog
vendor outside of Petco Park whoa they
don't mess around dude dude I heard that
like all the fruit carts and then the
hot dog carts they all have protection
from different gangs and stuff that's
not her too dude I heard they all have
beef they have only the hot dogs guys
have beef oh I don't get it yeah what do
you mean yeah why
so you know you know you read this
article you want to host it oh put the
things on put the shades on oh yeah
a 21 year old that's right a 21 year old
hot dog vendor was arrested for stabbing
a person after an alleged turf war
between out of town vendors oh my God
set up outside Petco Park late Saturday
night
San Diego Police responded
um in the downtown area of San Diego
around 10 30 p.m following reports of a
large brawl involving 10 to 15 people
um and there was you know
are you done yet
I'm not even saying anything in the
camera
company dude chill bro
chill dude I haven't done anything yeah
bro this field trip I just love on this
field trip already man just finish the
video already dude
DJ sucks so so like you said right there
is there is a huge protection weird
thing about who is a vendor where for
some reason yeah in a lot of these
sports stadiums the turf war dude dude
it's a full-on perfor but then um
sometimes it gets a little bit out of
hand so there was
um people who were witnessing this said
that a group of fruit of food fruit
vendors uh food vendors got into a
verbal argument resulting in 31 year old
man being stabbed in the back wow
and the San Diego Police had this
murderer had to use pepper spray to calm
down the situation because it was such a
huge crowd of people who were just
[__] brawling with each other about
it yeah whoa um I thought they had to
use pepper spray to [__] season the
hot dog and [__] oh dude well I mean
bacon wraps let's go
I feel like you would like pepper spray
as a as a positive I'm just do honestly
my little brother just didn't try it
chip challenge the other night what is
it a taco the Pocky chip the [__]
like 10 000 schools one chip that's like
super spicy yeah and it's one so the
greens bro we can [__] take the heat
no sweat right so my little brother he
took it on camera he does a show I do
crypticorner he does his show too and he
you know Kenny and he ate it on camera
on a stream and he was fine but then
afterwards he's like dude I was [__]
my [__] ass off oh that's the
drawback I think the spicy crazy it goes
in and it's fine but it goes out and
it's like fire fire anus [__] yeah
dude you probably get burning sensation
in your butthole for sure yeah you don't
want to deal with it and so he just told
me straight up don't do it every month
I'd be getting that now because I love
Sichuan food and I have to go oh it's
like a thing you know the way that they
do their kung pao chicken it's not
compound chicken it's like the Fried
Chicken it's like little fried chicken
bits with the it's like half of it is
just chili yep we're at it's like
Sichuan I think you should go we should
go because it's the part it's the part
of China where they love spices and it's
numbing it's like do you like numbing
Peppers the ones that literally numb
your tongue I like it when it tastes
good it does taste good it's different
from like Thai Spice where Thai Spice is
just painful sometimes it tastes [__]
good though yeah Ty's my favorite Ty's
one of my favorite spices you like the
little green chili we went to eat hot
pot that one time and it wasn't even
spicy but I remember afterwards like
that everyone had stomach you were
having some like issues oh yeah we
didn't expect that at all because it
wasn't spicy but then at home that was
like the [__] now I know how the
universe started the [__] big bag and
everything do you do spices work like
regular like just Flamin Hots or
whatever I don't like pour it on
anything but not like real deal like
crazy [__] do you guys sweat when you
eat spicy oh yeah if it's
yeah I like a good sweat when I eat
sometimes to be honest I love it me too
I frankly love it me too
um so yeah it's territorial [__] it's
crazy but you know that's actually
normal like when you're franchising like
like a McDonald's they have like you
know like a two mile radius away from
this or five mile radius so it's like
they I think because those contracts are
so sophisticated the territories are
built into how you franchise things they
just don't have contracts with each
other yet so they just gotta like step
up to each other yeah but then again too
right if you're coming out of a ball
game yeah you need [__] four or five
of those cards you need a shitload yeah
[__] ton to be able to service outside
of crypto it's like the whole [__]
sidewalk yeah yeah you ever seen that
one snake can only take what like
[__] 20 people at the crypto Center
crypto.com yes
is crypto.com still alive yeah they're
somehow I still got my FTX like app I
still use it right the app was fine I
always just use it for Price tracking
yeah I never actually used FDX me
neither yeah like well I'm more of a woo
guy I can't tell dozens of those carts
out there yeah you know what it seems
like outside of crypto.com Arena like
they used to be more sporadic and
everybody's kind of just like trying to
get you to go to their Taco spot yeah
but recently it looks like they all
worked together now and they're all just
they have a big guy yeah they make a
wall yeah and a great wall and it makes
it makes it like make sense like they're
really working and some of them have the
same uh photo on their cart if you've
seen that like they'll have like a
cohesive thing that looks like oh that's
one tribe one franchise one Squad yeah
when I was going to like the protests
during lockdown and before
um I thought it was really interesting
because no matter what the issue is
Mexican ends are always there hooking
people up when they're hungry love it
yeah true they look out it's undeniable
they don't care they're like hey it's a
gay parade they're like you want hot dog
and then they're like hey we're fighting
for rights they're like you want to hold
that the tamale guy is the [__] bomb
oh yeah you get the tamales from a guy
with like a pickup truck and that's
gonna be fire like the guy's grandma
made him that morning like you know
they're good in a bathtub yeah honestly
yeah probably I feel like they still
compete even within the thing a little
bit because I remember that like if you
were to let's say two are right next to
each other out of like seven in a row if
you buy your hot dog from this guy and
you like oh I need a napkin and you ask
this guy he'll say no interest because
like my friend tried to do that and they
were like no you bought it from that guy
you get it from him because like they're
still on their own resources too like if
this guy runs out of some [__] he's
assed out so he's like oh he bought it
here you go there yeah yeah makes sense
yeah it does it does I'm into that I
just always wonder though because like
you know every time I got a bacon
wrapped hot dog like the next day I'm
like what the [__] man why did I do that
because there's there's something about
the bacon wrap the night of oh there's
like the guilt of like supporting the
minorities
the guilt is unbearable
I should have kept the stand over I was
like is there a Nathan's guy here um
what's your name what's your name yeah
yeah
Nathan's guy it was part of the
experience though right like when you
come out of a concert or a big event you
want a la dog and it tastes so good
another night it's all steaming but let
me get to my point you put the mail and
all that on everything give me the word
I go what did the chef intend give me
that do you do you guys think that
Pink's Hot Dogs is good I think it's
overrated I've only had it when I was
high and it was [__] good I wouldn't
wait in line for it yeah and I'd rather
go to a Like a downtown dog or something
really yeah okie dokie yeah yeah like
I'd rather get a [__]
um Dodger Dog like at the grocery store
I'd rather
maybe it wasn't a hot dog maybe it was
the weed the thing that people will say
though is that you got the wrong one
because that pinks are so many [__]
options it's not like in and out where
you're like you have the burger but like
it pinks there's like so many different
types of hot dog they're gonna go oh
because you didn't get it with this on
it you get the PB J one yeah
I want to eat it
you guys had a PB J Burger before no no
is it good there's a place called Grill
mall I [__] love gorilla Mall yeah
and Alhambra it's really good and they
do like a grape jelly with like peanut
butter it sounds crazy it throws me off
I'm like I don't know it sounds wild
yeah that's too wild it works so well
it's my favorite burger place really
like they're they have really good can
you take us to a burger place nearby
a totally different restaurant no they
got this order they got this burger
called the pig Champion so it's like a
half pound [__] Patty medium rare
[__] juicy as [__] and then they have
two slices of fried Ham on top so that
when you bite into has that nice little
pop then you have like the the greens
and you have a sunny side up egg and
they point the yolk in your direction so
when you bite it just drizzles into the
hole very well God damn that's cool it's
a it's a really good burger joint that
sounds good hot dog wise I still think
Costco's hot dogs better than pink yeah
100 100 because of the value and at the
end of the day you're still eating a
[__] hot dog
and I love spending like 2.50 on my
entire lunch that's what I mean you
can't beat that yeah even when you go to
the like a Dodger game I'll get a
[__] hot dog and the savings are
passive after this number I'm telling
you